emil how did it feel to sit across from
a billionaire knowing that you could
have [ __ ]
jesus christ
that's pretty [ __ ] up to say what
don't you think so his [ __ ] bodyguard
just drops down from the roof right now
it was weird honestly it was really
i mean i i said to him i was like
honestly thank you for doing this never
in all my life did i think i would get
to talk to a
tech billionaire these are genuine
questions that i have we you know we
asked him some serious questions about
like
his role in all these things outside of
gamestop you know like i looked into a
lot of he's been a he's been a
controversial figure
and and robin hood has been a
controversial company
for a long time even before all that and
so we really got to talk to him about
that and
yeah it was
amazing to actually
get to get answers from him and ask him
about his responsibility and you know
what he feels his role is in making sure
people are educated and using these
tools he's developing and he had some
canned answers that sucks like i asked
him for a timeline about the gamestop
thing and he just gave me a very canned
answer so i tried to ask him again again
a canned answer and then i was like can
you just give me
day by day
before january 28th what happened and
then he finally did
but it did you ask him did citadel
reach out to you [ __ ] [ __ ] we didn't
ask a pointed question like that i
really wish that i had well because he
kind of touched on it no we we talked
about it and yeah but we didn't ask
directly i'm sorry um
no yeah we didn't directly but we kept
playing with them and being like at one
so this is the fun part i don't want to
how close are you in kane griffin well
so i don't want to i don't actually want
to go for what
i don't actually want to do this to him
because i don't think it's fair but i
wish we could we basically got him to
say a couple of things he shouldn't have
as a joke and i kept being like we're
gonna clip that because
you know i was like we were asking about
the ken griffin thing and we were like
and then he made a joke of like yeah and
the white house was calling trying to
like shrug it off and so i said okay so
so you joe biden and ken griffin get
together and then he says like and
collude to like
you know [ __ ] over everyone and i was
like we're clipping it
he did say no he then repeated it back
he said yeah me joe biden ken griffin
you heard it here first
he was on tmv studios yeah i'm showing
her mindset but he uh
the best part was
we are i mean we mentioned it to you
guys but i got him a hat
that actually should we blow this
because this is a fun thing if if people
are going to watch them yeah
you got him a hat which i know you got
him and you told me about it and yeah
very funny
this episode will come out after that
one so yeah
yeah but this gets a lot of people who
might not tune in to trillionaire
mindset and so if you guys are
interested in checking out there's some
very fun things that yeah
there's a special hat it's a hat gag
um it's another hat you know remember
when you guys laughed when they brought
us yeah remember that haha funny
this one's
very fun and this is for anyone who was
a little
uh they were definitely people who were
annoyed that we were having them on we
mentioned because we did a gamestop
recup recap the previous week and we had
mentioned we're very excited because you
know the end result of all this is that
we're having vlad on to talk
and there were definitely a good amount
of people who were like unsubscribed do
you guys suck i can't believe you would
have them on and i think
if you're one of those people
go check it out i think you're not gonna
be
we weren't it wasn't a [ __ ] robin
hood commercial
like which i think they might have
wanted it to be but um right and and i
feel like it's not yeah what you would
assume
the interview is gonna be like it's
funnier than you're gonna i think it's
unexpected and we ask him very real
questions
and it's crazy he let you guys lick his
nipples hey i didn't think he was gonna
go for it but i said it vlad's game you
see you see how ben's licking his lips
he can't stop thinking about it he was
wearing a what they taste like buttoned
up shirt it tasted like salty
a little salty yeah
very smooth i mean not unlike the man's
hair
very smooth
he was uh he was a he was uh he had huge
hands i remember pointing that out to
him
and now
yeah
well now also i'm like oh [ __ ] that was
that the drugs or was that me
that is funny i remember looking down
and going
it's fine and then we held them all
hands look like a baseball those giant
baseball hands
he put up his hands
with them what an acid thing to do he
did he fully put up hands and we
compared
wow we're close your hands are hot why
are they so hot are you sick you're
sucking on a cough drop he's running a
fever
yeah
the show must go on
my hands are i've been sitting on them
oh oh that's why okay remember do you
remember uh matt's
matt's story
about the meet and greet that he did or
that kid
like do you remember that oh yeah yeah
he was he was our tour manager was like
tour managing someone else and he was
doing a meet and greet and like normally
the people come up and they like hug
whoever the person is and then give
their phone to matt
he takes a picture and
so he goes up and like hugs whoever it
is and then like gets really close to
matt gives him his phone and matt's like
the hot the phone's like all sweaty and
he's like dude you're all right you're
sweating he's like yeah i just got a
fever
and then takes the picture and walks
away and madden what the [ __ ] dude was
that pre or post is that coco covered
bro still like that was you guys
like you don't want to get near someone
that has a flu i i took a covet test
last night and i swabbed my nose so bad
it bled
jesus christ
i mean not that [ __ ]
going hard it wasn't like that okay i
should refrain in circles it was just so
dry and first is everything okay yeah
everything's fine everything's fine are
you doing good
the instructions were also in spanish
because i don't know
why is that funny
did you just take acid could you read it
perfectly uh no but i do speak a little
spanish and that was last night i took
over this morning
that means put in the yeah see
do you
[Laughter]
you're gonna give me the giggles man you
better watch out i feel bad i'm laughing
directly into the microphone and i'm
sorry for anyone laughing it's okay i'm
listening
i feel like yeah all right never
mind and that's not we can't say that
what can't you say that i feel like i
gained weight since last time
you could definitely say that that's
staying in
i don't know listen wait since what your
last
[Laughter]
[Music]
and then you were talking about your
covenant test
okay okay okay
i feel like i gained weight since the
last time we were on here why do you why
do you feel like that because i just
feel like i did because i did i've been
eating
like crap and
you know it's not good for me
i feel great but we had
i'm much
i've been um you're at the gym in the
morning talking you're talking to me
from the gym i hurt my back
out and i'm back to where i want to be i
figured out some new hip exercises where
are they
oh well that was the thing i was only
stretching my back
yeah and then my and so and i got a deep
tissue massage for the first time
because like i was like my [ __ ] is so
[ __ ] up i like
during christmas i had like a pinched
nerve everything was all [ __ ] and then
i know about it someone was like it's
all about your hips you got to open them
up so i've been doing all these that's
what sucks i'm still working out but
literally
before i work out i have to stretch for
like a half hour and then after i have
to stretch for like 15 minutes
so it takes the same problem i used to
with your hips oh not my hips but a lot
of stretching because my pinched nerve
yeah but now i'm good yeah me too what's
it to you
gordon hey it's none of my business
fellas big boy you guys backs and your
hips are all your business and none of
my own
my back is probably going to be [ __ ]
when i get older i just slip the spanish
in there to see if i can [ __ ] with you
what did you say poppy or something no
what did you say that's what the ladies
tell you huh
they don't call me papi you [ __ ] look
at them and you're like call me poppy no
i do not that's what you said 10 minutes
ago i mostly say sorry
[Laughter]
i'm sorry and are you sure
[Laughter]
i did i i can't remember if i told you
guys this story but one time i was
playing
one time i was playing frisbee golf
with my friend brian and there was a
cute girl
on the course because it was a park but
also you could play frisbee golf on it
and she was under the the tree out there
on this hole and she was on a blanket
reading a book or something and i was
like dang she looks pretty cute well
anyway i got a tee off so i hit it i
threw the disc and it hit the tree and
landed right on her blanket and i was
like
this is
this is fate yeah and i walked up and i
was so nervous i was like 25
and um got to talking to her i asked her
if she had a boyfriend which is a stupid
question to ask you don't you
because it implies someone else you know
owns them or something what i think it
absolutely does not i remember being
told like don't ask if they've got a
boyfriend because they have the autonomy
to say whether or not they want you to
give you their phone number i guess but
it's also respectful to be like hey
do you have a boyfriend like i don't
know yes yeah okay whoops well i'm wrong
there well wait i don't know i'm not i
don't so i okay then i was fine that's a
weird question asked after you throw a
disc at someone's hand
usually it's like hey i'm sorry about it
well so after all that i then asked if
uh she wanted to go on a date sometime
and she said yeah and then i said
are you sure no
no yeah i know no buddy i believe you me
i know
cause then she did give me her phone
number and i was just
i never went i think they called that a
pick me
yeah something are you sure your
boyfriend might get mad
no we don't
i know you just said yes but it can
really be you don't have to be
nice to me
no i definitely she definitely went to
her friends and was like i met this
frisbee golf player who is exuding
confidence it was in the middle of a
weekday so you know he doesn't have a
job yeah
it was and i didn't
he wasn't he wasn't very confident
that's so weird frisbee golf is so hot
yeah
oh my god how sexy is frisbee golf
you